hello everyone and welcome to this
session of smart contracts my name is
Sarah and I'm part of the simple learn
team so let's get started and understand
what is a smart contract what's in it
for us today let's understand why do we
need a smart contract what is a smart
contract usage of solidity for building
smart contract advantages or smart
contract blockchain implementation of
smart contracts we will look at certain
examples of voting and digital token and
also we will take another use case of
how smart contract help us do
crowdfunding now why smart contract now
let's take a look traditionally how
contracts used to happen if suppose two
parties a and B have to get into a
contract they will utilize the services
of a third party whom they have to trust
and get the contract executed now with
the introduction of smart contracts and
the technology which is evolving it
removes the dependency on such third
parties and automates the execution of
such smart contracts so if we compare
traditional versus the new smart
contract in traditional we used to have
government's lawyers or any other third
party on which we can trust in smart
contracts we don't need any third party
we don't need any intermediate execution
time definitely there is higher at
execution time in traditional contracts
because as many number of middlemen and
their intermediary layers that many
number of days and time takes smart
contract is just a matter of minutes it
gets executed because it is automated
programmable running on a computer and
it has some predefined conditions the
remittance if any remittance of either
of the parties have to happen then it is
a manual process approvals workflows
processes
and these manual processes take time
under traditional contracting system but
in a smart contract as the conditions
are predefined pre embedded as soon as a
condition is met the remittance happens
automatically either of the parties who
have to be credited with an amount is
corrected automatically and that is the
primary advantage of using a smart
contract transparency not available 100%
in traditional contracts the
transparency is bound peripheral between
the parties and the entities and the
intermediaries involved as compared to
smart contract transparency is 100%
available 24 by 7 online anyone can go
and review audit and validate the
transactions executed by the smart
contracts archiving archiving is a big
difficult problem for traditional
contracts as most of the transactions
are paper-based or the records are
maintained offline it becomes very
difficult to maintain and identify the
traceability provenance of all the
transactions which have happened in a
traditional contract whereby in a smart
contract it becomes easy as all the
transactions have happened through the
smart contract there is a hundred
percent traceability available from the
provenance point of view you can trace
the transaction from its day one the
point of origin till presently
and archiving is automatically happening
the log the audit the transaction
history is automatically getting
generated security definitely is a
concern in traditional contracts as the
intermediate reason involved manual
processes involved security can be
compromised at any level at any stage
but in its Marc contract the security is
maintained through cryptography mainly
through public key infrastructure the
public and private key infrastructure it
is a very secure way of maintaining
security and cryptography of the
transactions using a smart contract cost
yes traditional contracts are expensive
the cost of transaction is high as
compared to smart contracts as the
middlemen are involved smart contract
the cost is low as we don't have any
intermediaries and only the cost of
transaction is charged by the underlying
infrastructure of the blockchain Network
which is running the smart contract
signatures its manual process all the
transactions are signed manually and
verified manually but here in the smart
contracts
all the transactions are digitally
signed using the private key of the
entities and can only be decoded by the
public key shade by the parties involved
in the smart contract so in a nutshell
smart contracts give us n number of
advantages the primary advantages are
listed here and these are the advantages
which enforce us to move towards an
economy and to a system where we start
using smart contracts for our
transactions to avoid any disputes to
keep the transaction cost low thereby
giving the advantage to the end consumer
now what is a smart contract let's
consider a real-life example where you
are taking out a chocolate from a
vending machine you deposit a $2.00 node
in a vending machine after that you hit
even button which is mapped against the
chocolate bar that you want to buy as a
result a liver in vending machine moves
and pushes out the chocolate so
basically even button is programmed to
the liver in order to move the chocolate
out now a smart contract is very similar
to a vending machine it eliminates the
need of an intermediary in case of the
vending machine is replacing a direct
seller and allowing you to make a
purchase without a middleman and it
eliminates the need of escrow services
now smart contracts are specific see
tooting contract which contain the terms
and conditions of an agreement between
the parties and the peers who are
involved in that agreement so the terms
and conditions of an agreement are
written in a piece of code and it is
executed on a blockchain based
decentralized platform now these
agreements Silla dates exchange of any
digital asset it could be digital
currency
it could be shares it could be property
or it could be anything which you want
to transact so a blockchain based v
centralized platform gives you a
democratic system where the transactions
are authorized by the majority of the
participants and the identity of the
participants is also kept anonymous now
let's consider an example where rachel
is at the airport and her flight is
delayed but this inconvenience could
have been beneficial to Richard as smart
contract insurance would ensure she is
given a compensation for the flights
delay instantly so just imagine there is
a smart contract which the insurance
company has already deployed and its
monitor
during the flights delayed Rachel has
already taken that insurance for delay
in flights so as soon as that condition
is met for a delay of flight above X
amount of hours for example two hours
then in that case the insurance company
will automatically get that trigger and
Rachel will be credited with that amount
for which she is insured in her account
so let's see how smart contract can be
helpful here so X a flight delay
insurance is one of the examples of
aetherium smart contract AXA is an
insurance company the smart contract is
linked to the databases that record
flight status so that smart contract is
connected to the databases it is
fetching that information and evaluating
the delay it enables automatic
compensation when there is a delay for
two hours or more so that is the
condition when the flight delay is
beyond two hours then the insurance
contract will get executed and Rachel
will get paid a smart contract is
created based on the terms and
conditions so condition compensation is
equal to flight delays less than two
hours based on the code smart contract
holds the company's money until a
certain condition is satisfied this
smart contract is submitted to the nodes
on the blockchain
network to their EVMs for evaluation
so EVM is a runtime compiler to execute
smart contracts code it is the brain it
is the electronic virtual machine which
executes the smart contract all nodes on
the network executing the code using the
EVM must come to the same result because
all the EVMs would have the same copy of
the smart contract deployed if flight is
delayed two or more our smart contract
will be self executed and the
compensation amount will be given to
Rachel and that is the objective of the
smart contract without involvement of
any middleman paperwork which ritual has
to do to submit and then the insurance
company going through the manual process
all that has been bypassed and rachel
has been compensated directly now let's
understand why do we need solidity for
developing our smart contracts now here
comes the important question which
programming language does not contract
use there are two widely used
programming languages for writing Scania
smart contract solidity
serpent however on bloxy platform
solidity is widely used for implementing
smart contracts and this is what we were
going to talk about in our subsequent
slides
now solidity is a high-level programming
language used for implementing smart
contracts it enables to check the
program at run time rather than compile
time solidity is a turing-complete
language it has all the conditions all
the while loops for route operators etc
which are there in any mature
programming language in order to write
your code in order to write your
conditions if you have certain loop if
you have while conditions etc now what
are the advantages of smart contracts as
we have already discussed there are no
intermediate reason vult the process
executes without the need of a third
party it's an automated process they are
automated with the code which eliminates
manual effort for execution it's the
high speed highly computed smart
contracts which runs on programming code
the speed of its execution is higher
than a traditional contract as data is
stored in the be centralized system the
chances of modifying the data is
difficult and I would say more than
impossible accuracy based on the
requirement terms and condition of a
contract is recorded accurately so as
soon as any transaction is recorded it
is registered on a blockchain network
and it is immutable transaction no one
can modify or make changes in any record
which has been added onto a blockchain
it was through a smart contract now
let's take a look at certain blockchain
implementation of a smart contract using
block came in voting process can
eliminate
voting mal practices a centralized
voting system faces a lot of problems
when it comes to tracking votes they
could be manipulated identities they
could be manipulation in counting there
could be biased decision making a smart
contract is introduced to eliminate all
these mal practices there are certain
predefined terms and conditions which
already set in the contract no voter can
vote from a digital identity for of any
other voter the counting is foolproof
every vote is registered on a blockchain
network and the counting is happening
automatically without any interference
from a third party or dependency on a
manual process so terms and condition
each ID should be attributed to just one
vote the validation is done by the users
on the Block C Network itself so the
voting process can be in a public
blockchain or it could be in a
decentralized autonomous organization
based blockchain setup also but it is
100 percent transparent and every voting
transaction is recorded result every
voters would get recorded on the ledger
and that information cannot be modified
it is transparently publicly available
for audit and verification now let's
take a look at one of the examples of
our voting solidity contract so here we
have our voting solidity contract it is
built in solidity and I'll just give you
a brief overview of what are the primary
functions in this so if we look at this
particular contract this contract gives
you certain basic parameters like what
should be the minimum number of
participants or proposals which are
required for voting then what should be
the minimum amount of time for debate
that needs to pass before the vote can
be executed then the margin of votes for
majority a proposal passes if there are
more than 50% of the votes plus the
margin so basically we are defining what
is the winning condition what is the
majority margin for any world to be
accepted then you have data structure
where you are accepting the proposals
right and then subsequently we are
defining data structures for members who
are participating in the proposals who
are submitting the proposals we are
fetching the addresses of the members
basically this is the digital identity
of the members who are submitting the
proposals and etc so this smart
contracts basically allows you to create
a voting system where you can add
members we can remove the members you
can change certain voting rules based on
certain conditions like if you want to
increase the minimum forum if you want
to change the debating period minutes or
the majority rule changes then this is
the function for submitting a new
proposal for which the voting has to
happen so basically this example is
about if I have to take a vote within a
decent
autonomous organization for a particular
decision so rather than a central
authority taking a decision you can have
a voting mechanism within your
organization to give a majority to your
proposal if you get the majority the
proposal is accepted otherwise reject
then there are peripheral functions like
check proposal code then there is a
voting function the actual vote happens
and for a particular proposal you start
increasing or decreasing the number of
votes then you execute the proposal if
the majority has been achieved now let's
take a look on how to deploy a smart
contract so here we have our voting
smart contract now we will take a look
on how to deploy our voting smart
contract on the etherium test network
called rob stone this is our voting
smart contract now when you open remakes
you should also have meta mask which is
a chrome plug-in installed this is a
utility in order to connect to the Rob
stone test net which is a etherium test
network so basically you say Rob
standard ether scan dot IO and this is
the etherium test network on which we
will deploy our contract so once you
login into the meta mask you will have a
account created and in that account you
should have some test ethers already so
that you can use them to deploy a
contract so when you create an account
on Rob's turn you can buy certain ethers
using the Rob stone test faucet
so when you reach this site that option
test faucet has already taken the
address for the account for which you
are erasing the request and you can
raise request of one ether now whenever
this transaction will get processed your
account balance will get incremented by
one so as I already have eaters in it I
can utilize it to deploy my contract now
in order to compile and deploy my
contract I have copy pasted it here and
if I go to my run my remix as already
communicated via injected web 3 to the
meta mas and taken my account which has
seven point eight three ether
now I need to do some settings
you
now as my contract is compiled you can
see it has taken all the contracts you
can see the drop down and Congress is my
major contract now I will deploy my
contract on the run section you will be
able to see in the drop down the name of
the contracts which are there in my
smart contract like I had own token
recipient then there's an interface and
there is a Congress I need to deploy my
Congress contract now in order to deploy
this contract there is a constructor
which requires certain inputs so I can
give certain values like what minimum
number of proposals an 800 then minimum
number of debates 10 and margin of votes
for majority I say deploy now as soon as
I'll click deploy it is going to request
me for gas because when the contract
gets deployed it will deduct certain
ethers from my account so when I will
say submit
if you notice now this transaction has
got initiated on the Rob's train ether
scan dot IO I click on it so this is the
transaction on which the contract is
getting deployed it is taking time and
the contract is getting processed on the
etherium Network now once it will get
deployed we will be able to see the
address at which the contract has got
reiated and deployed now as you can see
my contract has got deployed at the
address 0 xcc I can load it so this is
the contract address and this is the
amount of actual ether which was spent
from my account in order to deploy the
contract
now there are certain attributes on the
option either scan which you can go and
check you can verify and publish or
smart contract over here so that others
can also view the code and utilize your
smart contract and if you go and check
your meta mask this is the transaction
which has just been done in your account
and if you click it will take you to the
same transaction which we open there now
after you have deployed the contract you
can interact with your contract directly
through remix just to test your contract
all the pink members are the ones which
make changes onto the blockchain and all
the blue ones are the ones which are
only performing read operations so in
order to do any read operation you will
not be requested to spend any gas so
there will be no pop-ups for meta masks
requesting for gas pending but if you do
any of these pink actions then you will
be required to spend gas as it will be
requiring to make some changes onto the
blockchain so this was a example of a
voting smart contract and this will be
available as a link for you to take a
look now all our other contracts which
we will be covering subsequently will be
deployed in a similar fashion on the
robson test net now let's take another
example if you want to use smart
contract to issue your own
cryptocurrency or called digital token
you can use aetherium based mat contract
to create your own digital tokens for
performing transactions in design and
issue your own digital currency create a
tradable computerized token that can be
utilized as a currency share or any
asset which you want to transact these
tokens use a standard coin API like in
case of aetherium we have
standardizations of ERC to 0 etc which
allows contract to automatically access
any wallet for exchange as a result you
build a tradable token with a suffix
applied and this particular platform
becomes like a central bank issuing our
digital money your smart contract
becomes the bank issuing the money so
let's take this example here so this is
a implementation of a ERC 2-0 token
which is a specification by it
and the primary attribute for this token
is that you need to provide a name of
your token a symbol the decimals to
which you support and the most primary
is the predefined supply so just like in
an economy you have limited supply of
money there also you have to define what
will be the supply of your tokens and it
will be capped that will be discipline
so you need to redefine these parameters
and then you create certain data
structures within solidity to keep a tab
on the balances of the entities to which
you are giving the tokens and how much
allowance you want to keep for address
then there are certain methods which you
have to implement as per the ER c20
specification like transfer transfer
from approve and call etc so all these
methods in a typical token allows you to
do the transaction send and receive your
custom token among multiple parties so
this would also be available as a link
for you to take a look now let's take
another example of a use case for
crowdfunding using smart contracts to
crowd fund your project so suppose you
want to start a business and for a
business you need a lot of funding which
is required but who would lend it money
to someone whom they don't trust how
will you generate that money for such
problems smart contractor is a major
rule with aetherium you can build a
smart contract that will hold a
contributors funds unless a given date
or a goal is met based on the result the
funds will be released to the contract
owners or will be sent back to the
contributors so basically you can create
a crowdfunding project for yourself if
you want to raise certain amount of
money and the contributors or the
investors will give you the money but
the amount will be kept on hold till the
time your project goal or date has been
made and accordingly the investors will
get your the token which you have
developed for crowdfunding in earth or
is account accordingly now centralized
crowdfunding system has plenty of issues
with management systems so therefore a
dhow a decentralized autonomous
organization is utilized for
crowdfunding the terms and conditions
are transparently set in the contract
every
visual participating in the crowdfunding
is given a token and the token is
credited to their aetherium base account
now every contribution gets recorded on
the blockchain because then the token
transfer has happened from the DAO to
the individual investor that transaction
get recorded on the blockchain network
so let's quickly take a look at the
contract for a crowd sale also so a
crowd sale contract provides you the
basic attributes like what is the goal
of the funding how much money you need
to raise what is the amount raised
real-time you can keep a track what is
the deadline right and what is the price
of the token in etherium basically what
is the your token amount in ethier
then there could be that you might give
certain tokens in reward then you can
have attributes for your reward and then
you have your methods in order to keep a
check that once you have received the
funds you can withdraw the funds you can
check whether you have reached the goal
for funding and then you have the
methods for transferring tokens from the
sender to your own account this
particular kind of contract allows you
to maintain and keep a check on amount
of funding you have received or you want
to receive have you achieved your target
who are the investors in Europe token
how much percentage share belongs to
your account and how much percentage
share has been already been distributed
all amongst the investors etc so
everything can be tracked so the smart
contract can build in such a fashion
that there are methods and utilities
available in order to run your entire
crowdfunding so this contract is also
available in the link and you can take a
look so what are the key takeaways today
why do we need smart contract what is a
smart contract what are the advantages
of smart contract blockchain based
implementations or smart contract and
the use case of crowdfunding using smart
contracts I hope you all had a great
learning session and I'll meet you in my
next session
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here